president Trump's banana terror against
the media over the past 24 hours
labeling them in the opposition party
after their coverage of yesterday's
meeting with Democrats it all started
with a late-night Twitter storm quote
the mainstream media has never been more
dishonest than it is now NBC and MSNBC
are going crazy
they reports stories purposely the exact
opposite of the facts they're truly the
opposition party working with the Dems
may even be worse than fake news CNN if
that is possible then as he's leaving
for the border Trump said this the media
which I call the opposition party a lot
of the media in coordination with the
Democrats they're not talking about the
Democrats folding I didn't pound on
tables I didn't raise my voice that was
the lie I very calmly said if you're not
gonna give us strong borders bye-bye and
I left I didn't rent I didn't rape like
you reported I very calmly walked out of
the room I didn't pass the table I
should have but I didn't smash the table
and while the media continues to try to
trap Trump and Ally
CNN's Jim Acosta botched this attempt to
take down to the president here are some
of the steel slats that the president's
been talking about right here as you can
see yes you can't see through these
slats to the other side of the us-mexico
border but as we're walking along here
we're not seeing any kind of imminent
danger there are no migrants trying to
rush toward this fence here in the
McAllen Texas area
as a matter of fact there are some other
businesses behind me along this Highway
there's a gas station Burger King and so
on but no sign of the national emergency
that the president has been talking
about as a matter of fact it's pretty
tranquil down here pretty tranquil
because walls work Jim I think he just
made the president's point for him Greg
that was paid for by the Donald Trump
twenty20 reelection campaign I mean he's
in a spot at a wall and says see there's
no problem
dumber than we initially thought which
says a lot or I'm thinking this could be
a really long prank like you know Andy
Kaufman
when Andy Kaufman pretended to be this
in character all the way till his death
I think that he is playing this role and
by the way it's amazing look the media
has no credit credibility on this issue
because just weeks ago they called this
a humanity and humanity Aryan crisis
right there were people rushing to the
border there were Caravan so where
people die they're suffering - and then
when Donald Trump agrees and says this
is a humanitarian crisis they turn it
into this mocking tone what crisis
there's no crisis here look at this wall
I mean they're the biggest hypocrites it
is hard not to despite it's hard to like
them it's easy to despise the problem is
that Obama called this humanitarian
crisis drop tweeted that out and the
media is on record so many times as
having defended him and so many times as
having come in to defend Chuck Schumer
and all those Democrats that voted for
border security that now they're
panicked about how they can flip that
now to hate Trump for espousing the very
same things that all those Democrats did
that the media backed them up on that's
their problem I don't get that at all so
the media of all of them gather down
there to look at the photo-op here and
you have the Border Patrol and they make
an announcement that 90% of the traffic
comes in this sector where there's no
barrier okay six only six percent of the
traffic comes where there is a barrier
you'd think the media would take an
expert opinion like this and maybe write
it down in one of their news stories and
show hey the experts on the ground say
walzwerk no they that's that's again
that's how you distort numbers here's
what here's the reality there's not a
wall across most of the border Jesse I
understand a very specific sector I
think really slows down okay let's let
me just say the media went down there
the President himself and I think a lot
of the anger at the media came from the
session with anchors that was supposed
to be off the record New York Times
reports the president's a
he didn't want to give the speech on
Tuesday night he didn't want to go to
the book didn't see the purpose and then
pointed the people behind him Kelly and
Conway Sarah Huckabee Sanders bill shine
and said these people think it's a good
idea apparently he didn't but here's the
reality you have a situation that
violated the after all so then if you
know what I thought this was the most
transparent president ever have it on
the record you guys certainly
mind-reader now you know exactly what
he's thinking at every time then he
retweets what so you retweet he doesn't
retweet the meeting he repeats her
retweets Brad Pascale Don bond G know
charlie okay so Trump is active on
social media Thank You Juan Dana so you
have these off-the-record things and and
then you go down there for this
opportunity to showcase the border the
media is following along do you think
this is gonna make any impact with the
press whatsoever but what are the thing
about the the author record being
violated I that is it I don't think it
was that egregious necessarily I would
not like it if it happened mean but I
also would not be surprised if there
weren't other people who were calling
Maggie Haberman the New York Times
reporter and telling her that exact same
thing because we know this is what
happens the White House will say that's
not true and then three months later you
find out that is exactly what happened
on the fact that the media how did we
find out today that the Democrats have
cracks in their coalition I've read that
in a Politico piece today because the
reporters are out there doing their jobs
it's like it's not all fake news like
some of the reporting has actually been
pretty good the other thing though that
bothered me is that the other day on The
Daily the New York Times podcast they
they turned this crisis thing into the
headline was it's a crisis of his own
making mm-hmm right because they said he
changed the asylum rules and how you
apply for asylum so that that's why all
these people flooded the border but that
doesn't if you go back to as Janet I was
saying the in the Obama administration
remember when that was a humanitarian
crisis they didn't say that that was
Obama's own making right and so it is
that is a frustrating thing because
there's clearly a bias there or
unwillingness
look back and do a fair comparison also
that the Mexican drug cartels and all
the drug trafficking and what's going on
in Mexico is also not part that that's
not Trump's fault he needs to broaden
this discussion people don't like the
term wall he needs to talk about yes he
need to talk about barriers but he also
needs to talk about going after these
cartels he need to talk about problems
he has with the State Department that
wants diplomacy all the time at the a
doesn't prioritize going after these
cartels and he needs to talk about
humanitarian crisis that Democrats have
been making that case for years and the
media backed them up that needs to be
the priority not just the fence all
right